[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video were going to be discussing
the lowest of the low the bottom of the
barrel the darkest of the duck the
wrongly convicted Azkaban prison is the
famous island fortress where dangerous
and dark witches and wizards are sent to
pay for their crimes against the
Wizarding World being sent to Azkaban is
a supreme punishment as the fortress is
desolate nearly inescapable and well
scary
while it's sort of a given that you're
going to have a bad time there it could
potentially be even worse if you happen
to make eye contact with some of the
other residents to the prison in an
effort to contain the most powerful dark
witches and wizards the fortress is used
as a last resort a place where the
ministry can rest easy sort of knowing
that the Dementors will keep the
prisoners in check we've heard of some
of our favorite characters being
wrongfully sent their first Hagrid who
was sent there for two months after
being wrongfully accused of reopening
the Chamber of Secrets and then of
course Sirius who was falsely accused of
murdering Pettigrew serving Voldemort
betraying the Potters and murdering 12
muggles I would imagine that going there
must give you some pretty thick skin
finding yourself suddenly immersed in an
environment where you are surrounded by
some of the darkest and most evil things
in the Wizarding World but haven't you
ever wondered who has actually spent
time in Azkaban prison in this video
we're going to be looking at in no
particular order five interesting cases
of witches and wizards that have been
imprisoned in the famous island fortress
we won't be looking at the serious
blacks or the Bellatrix's or any of the
obvious prisoners I want to look at
people who are less commonly associated
with the island prison number one
Percival Dumbledore described in his
younger years as a good-looking man with
eyes that seemed to twinkle Percival
Dumbledore was a pureblood wizard
husband to Kendra and father to ABBA
forth Ariana and Albus Percival Zelda's
son
Albus would later become headmaster of
Hogwarts and is considered by some to be
the greatest Wizard of all time when
Percival's daughter and Albus his sister
Ariana was six she was brutally
assaulted by three Mongol boys the
incident left Ariana with an inability
to control her magical abilities when
Percival found out about what had
happened to his daughter he furiously
attacked the three muggle boys for this
he was sentenced to Azkaban
Percival never explained the reason for
attacking the muggles to the ministry as
he feared that if they knew of her
condition she would be locked away in
st. Mungo's hospital this is due to her
existence being a hazard to the statute
of secrecy this led to much speculation
about Percival's crime and many believed
that the attack was driven by a
radicalized perspective on blood purity
which couldn't have been further from
the truth after being locked away in
Azkaban he died in the prison as he was
not an inherently bad person I'm sure he
never even tried to escape while we
don't have a lot of information that
supports Percival's level of power by
looking at his son we can infer that he
was probably quite a powerful man some
power is achieved through talent
tenacity and willingness to learn some
power is achieved through genetics and
bloodline and some power is achieved
through a combination of the two I
believe that his son Albus Dumbledore's
power can be attributed to a combination
of the two with an equal emphasis on
talent and genetics I think that Albus
is inherent genetic capability to
perform advanced magic was something
that was passed on through his father
and for this reason I think that
Percival was probably very powerful in
his own right next up we have Marvolo
gaunt Marvolo gaunt was a pureblood
wizard the father of merapi and Morphin
gaunt and the grandfather of
Lord Voldemort the gaunt family were
direct descendants of Salazar Slytherin
one of the extremely powerful four
founders of Hogwarts Marvolo gaunt with
his immediate family members lived in
poverty the result of centuries of
inbreeding instability and violence
within the family though the Gaunt's
were once very wealthy it has been
stated that the families lack of sense
coupled with a great liking for grandeur
meant that the family gold was
squandered several generations before
Marvolo was born marvelous son Morphin
was mentally deranged and showed little
consideration for Wizarding walls
particularly the statute of secrecy
which forbids witches and wizards from
performing magic in front of muggles
when Bob Ogden head of the Ministry of
Magic slaw enforcement Squad visited the
gaunt cottage chaos broke out and long
story short it resulted in a battle that
imprisoned both Marvolo and morphing
Marvel who was charged with attacking
wizard police resisting arrest
obstruction of justice attempted assault
on a witch and contempt of was anger
Mott Marvolo gaunt was found guilty on
all counts and was sentenced to six
months in the island prison though
Marvolo gaunt came from a powerful
magical bloodline he was not
particularly powerful himself this was
the result of bigotry and an inflated
sense of self derived from his pure
blood status because he came from a pure
bloodline he felt that he was above
books learning practice and well
everything that is required of a
powerful wizard however I hold the
belief that if Marvolo had lived his
life differently and had practiced magic
like any other witch or wizard he would
have been immensely powerful our genetic
makeup is so important when it comes to
what sort of things we are able to
achieve and Marvolo being a descendant
of Salazar Slytherin himself would have
likely had so much untapped power after
all he's the grandfather of Lord
Voldemort
next up we have Igor Karkaroff Igor
Karkaroff was a pureblood wizard and the
headmaster of durmstrang Institute
Karkaroff was a bit of a snake and
seemed to show allegiance to whoever was
in power at the time flip-flopping
between Voldemort and the ministry he
has a very dark past and when he was a
young Death Eater he would torture
muggles along with Antonin Dolokhov and
others while he was a Death Eater
Karkaroff was captured by famous hora
Alastor Moody and was promptly sent to
Azkaban when the time came for Cockroft
'san trial for his crimes he blurted out
the names of every Death Eater that he
could think of hoping that it would
alleviate his sentence by giving the
ministry the name
Augustus Rookwood the ministry took
leniency with Roth and he was
eventually released from Azkaban it was
shortly after his release that he
assumed the position of headmaster at
durmstrang
next up we have Sturges pod nor Sturges
pod Moore was a wizard an order of the
Phoenix member he fought in both the
first and second Wizarding wars with the
order and was part of the advance guard
joined by Moody Lupin Tonks Shakur bolt
Doge tickle Vance and Jones the advanced
guard helped to bring Harry from number
four privet Drive to number 12 Grimmauld
place on August the 12th 1995 Padma was
posted at the entrance to the Department
of mysteries in an effort to prevent
Death Eaters from stealing the prophecy
while standing guard he was placed under
the Imperius curse by Lucius Malfoy and
was ordered to steal the prophecy for
the Death Eaters after breaking in
Padma was discovered by ministry member
Eric munch and Padma was promptly
sentenced to Azkaban Sturgis is said to
be an all-around stand-up guy a loyal
member of the order and a great friend
to Albus Dumbledore
though Padma was innocent he did serve a
considerable amount of time in Azkaban
for a crime that he technically didn't
commit he was there from August 1995
until March 1996 after it was proven
that he was under the Imperius curse
Padma was released from prison and he
rejoined the order and lastly we have
mundungus Fletcher another order of the
Phoenix member Mandela's Fletcher was a
half-blood wizard with a rich history of
criminal activity it's actually
interesting that he was a member of the
order at all given his disreputable
background due to his reputation
mungus was not well-liked within the
order but was deeply loyal to its cause
the result of Dumbledore getting
mundungus out of trouble in some way we
don't really know the details of it
after Sirius died mundungus began
raiding am a 12 Grimmauld place looting
and selling all of the valuables that
existed inside of the order's
headquarters Harry actually caught
mongers doing this and he dissipated no
one knew where he went for quite some
time but it was later revealed in the
Daily Prophet that mundungus had been
sent to Azkaban for impersonating an
inferiors he wasn't in Azkaban for
particularly long less than a year and
eventually escaped during the mass
breakout described by Shacklebolt
in 1997 during the Battle of the 7
Potter's everyone was grouped into pairs
mungus was paired up with famous aura
Alastor Moody and is partly responsible
for Moody's death mundungus is a coward
and when the two were approached by
Voldemort he dissipated leaving moody
all alone the killing curse that was
meant for mundungus ended up hitting
Moody and that concludes the list of
five prisoners of Azkaban that I found
to be interesting when we think of
prisoners in Azkaban our minds always go
to Bellatrix Lestrange and Sirius Black
or at least that's where my mind goes
there have obviously been many many more
prisoners over the course of the
fortresses history and this was just a
sample of
five that I thought were noteworthy if
you guys want more videos about
prisoners inside of Azkaban let me know
down in the comment section below until
next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]